ça fait un mois depuis le dernier serait
d'horreur vous savez ce que ça veut dire
vous êtes content ou pas bon ajarray de
faire durer comme d'habitude aujourd'hui
je vous racontais 3 expérience terrible
qui sont arrivés pour de break à trois
personnes d'ailleurs je pioche beaucoup
de ces histoires sur le saut brésil
let's not me it qui est sont des gens
qui racontent vraiment des expériences
par contre qu'ils ont vécu et a jamais
eu autant d'histoires poster que depuis
le confinement en fait comme les gens
s'ennuient ils vont raconter des trucs
sur le net beaucoup plus qu'avant pour
notre plus grand plaisir
on commence tout de suite avec
l'histoire des lieux qui a une histoire
qui parle d' intrusion des fractions à
domicile donc on a déjà traité 2 à
plusieurs fois dans cette vidéo serait
de voir sauf que là ça aurait pu
vraiment mal tourné quelques années
avant de raconter son histoire
elliott expliquent qu'ils vivaient au
nord de la californie il habitait dans
un quartier qui était à proximité d'une
banlieue donc c'était pas en milieu
hyper rural mais c'était pas non plus en
milieu hyper urbain
voilà il explique que c'est un entre
deux assez cool il précise que la zone
dans laquelle il habite n avait pas de
lampadaires et que donc il faisait très
sombre
là nous venons en au fait un soir
elliott rentrent du travail c'est
l'hiver la nuit et nuageuse et en
arrivant devant chez lui en voiture il
voit donc uniquement ce que les phares
de la voiture est clair est ce que la
lumière du porche est clair ce soir là
en sortant de sa voiture elliott sent
une odeur de cigarette
il trouve ça étrange parce qu'il n'a
jamais senti ça autour de sa maison et
j'ai donc un petit coup d'oeil à droite
à gauche sauf que il voit personne
il cherche pas plus que ça sortir des
oiseaux de cigarettes c'est un truc
assez fréquent même s'il a effectivement
c'était un petit indice de ce qui allait
suivre et leur explique qu'ils venaient
de sortir d'une énorme journée de boulot
et que du coup il était claquée et que
par conséquent ce soir là même s'il
était à peine 19 heures passées il a
décidé d'aller prendre une douche et de
se coucher un peu plus tard après s'être
couché elliott se réveille et il est
persuadé d'avoir entendu un bruit à
l'intérieur de la maison il explique que
ça n'a pas du tout inquiétés parce que
et dote en fait un ami qui passe
régulièrement chez lui pour se doucher
avant de rejoindre des cours qu'il prend
le soir il ya quand même un truc qui
mais elliott un peu sur ses gardes c'est
qu'habituellement son ami le prévient qu
est pas chez lui il y envoie un message
et après plusieurs secondes de silence
total il entend quelqu'un au rez de
chaussée qui se met à courir en
direction de l'état elliott comprend que
la personne dans la maison n'est pas son
ami il sort de son lit en une seconde et
il court vers son placard il explique
qu'au moment où il a ouvert la porte du
placard pour se cacher alain
avant de la refermer l'intrus se
trouvait déjà en haut des marches à
laitages elliott et donc caché dans son
placard et il entend l'intrus se diriger
vers la salle de bains
il explique que c'était probablement
parce que c'était la seule des trois
porte qui était entrouverte et que donc
le gars a dû penser qu elliott s'était
caché dans la salle de bains genre
derrière le rideau de douche ou une
connerie comme ça elliott est toujours
dans le placard de sa chambre et il
comprend qu'il a un tout petit peu de
temps pour éventuellement changer de
cachette et il en profite donc pour
ouvrir l'accès aux greniers qui se
trouve dans le plafond de son placard
heureusement que l'accès était là parce
que s'il accepte en dehors du placard il
aurait probablement fait du bruit en
sortant du placard
il explique que la porte de sa chambre
s'est ouverte au moment où il venait de
rentrer ses pieds à l'intérieur du
grenier l'intrus est alors dans la
chambre d'elliot en train de le chercher
après quelques dizaines de secondes
il va même ouvrir le placard placard
dans lequel je le rappelle se trouve
l'accès au grenier grenier dans lequel
se trouve elliott elliott il a à peu
près à un mètre de l'accès au grenier et
du coup il peut voir vaguement l'intrus
il s'agit apparemment d'une personne qui
porte un jean bleu salles et des bottes
de travail complètement usés après
plusieurs secondes à fouiller dans le
placard l'intrus conclut kelio tu n'es
pas là et donc repart et après être
parti elliott entend un gros cri de
colère et de frustration
venant de l'intrus il explique
d'ailleurs que ça lui a foutu la méga
trouille parce qu'il a compris
définitivement que ce mec était en train
de le chercher et qu'il était très en
colère de ne pas l'avoir trouvé bref
après ça l'homme qui est dans la maison
retourne au rez-de-chaussée est là
elliott entend toutes sortes de bruits
d'étagères qui tombe d'assiette qui se
cassent bref le gars est en train de
démolir le rez-de-chaussée d'elliot et
c'est à ce moment là qu'est les autres
réalise qu'il est un peu baiser parce
que quand il est parti se cacher dans le
placard il n'a pas eu le réflexe de
prendre son téléphone qui est
malheureusement toujours sur sa table de
nuit et clairement il a pas envie de
prendre le risque de descendre du
grenier pour aller prendre son téléphone
et de risquer de faire du bruit ce qui
va attirer le gars qui est toujours au
rez-de-chaussée dans la chambre il
décide donc d'attendre
accroupis dans le grenier et d'être
patient malgré les bruits de fraga qui
viennent du rez-de-chaussée de chez lui
et à partir du moment les bruits vont
cesser elliott décide de compter jusqu'à
1000 il fait ça pour se laisser une
marge de sécurité
et pour être sûr que le gars est bel et
bien partie avant de descendre du
grenier et d'appeler la police
en descendant du grenier le premier truc
et l'autre voie c'est son lit qui est
complètement renversées ne vous cachez
donc jamais sous votre lit c'est évident
il remarque aussi que son portable n'est
plus sur sa table de chevet et il ne le
trouve plus heureusement pour lui sur un
meuble de sa chambre il y a un téléphone
fixe
ce que d'ailleurs moi je n'ai pas chez
moi moi le gars pour monter je suis
baiser c'est fini et là tu appelle donc
la police grâce à sa ligne fixe et il
attend dans sa chambre jusqu'à l'arrivée
des policiers jusqu'à ce qu'ils les
entendent crié en bas en descendant pas
de surprise son appart est retournée et
le seul truc qui a disparu c'est un
couteau de son bloc de couteau de
cuisine
ce qui donne des frissons à elliott
puisqu'il comprend que le gars avait
pris un couteau pour se défendre
lorsqu'il le chercher la police a donc
découvert que la porte latérale de la
maison d'elliot avait été forcée à base
de pied de biche et c'était comme ça que
l'intrus s'était infiltré chez nous ils
ont aussi trouvé le long de la clôture
d'elliot des mégots et un stylo vider la
police explique elliot que les gens qui
fument de la méthamphétamine se servent
souvent de tubes de stylos vide et ses
lacs elliott se rappelle que quand il
est rentré chez lui il a senti une odeur
de cigarette
ce qui veut dire qu'en fait au moment où
il est arrivé chez lui il n'a pas fait
gaffe mais il y avait déjà quelqu'un qui
était l'un autour de chez lui en train
de fumer une clope
bref la conclusion de ça c'est quoi ces
cagnottes il a quand même dormi chez lui
ce soir là après avoir mis une étagère
devant la porte enfoncée
le lendemain il a appelé différentes
personnes pour bien évidemment réparer
sa porte est aussi installé des spots
qui s'allument automatiquement tout
autour de sa maison il a vécu encore
trois ans dans cette maison avant
d'emménager ailleurs et il n'a jamais eu
d'autres incidents par contre il
explique qu'il a pris une autre
précaution annoncé qu' ils expliquent
qu'ils s'étaient entraînés à sortir de
son lit le plus vite possible à
rejoindre le grenier en faisant le moins
de bruit possible ça l'a quand même un
peu trop ma et il a bien bad et à cause
de ça et on comprend tout talent fou
elliot on espère ne jamais avoir affaire
aux gars qui est venu chez toi voilà
laissez moi maintenant vous raconter
l'histoire de margaux qui s'est passé à
son université elle dans une université
à ces petites d'à peu près 500 personnes
elle est en deuxième année et tout se
passe bien dans sa classe se trouve un
garçon un peu particulier qui s'appelle
marc elle ne connaît pas plus que ça
mais il ya un cours dans sa journée où
elle est assise à côté de lui bref ce
gars socialement et pas très à l'aise et
elle s'en fiche ça la regarde pas tout
ce qu'elle sait de lui c'est
qu'apparemment il a eu une enfance un
peu compliquée pendant un de ses cours
de fin d'après midi l'agent des
ressources humaines de l'école qui vient
toquer à la porte de la classe le cpe
aux professeurs j'ai besoin que margot
me rejoigne immédiatement dans mon
bureau tous ceux à qui c'est arrivé vous
savez c'est l'un des plus gros coup de
pression que tu peux te prendre dans ta
vie celle ci qu'il est recherché en
cours directement ça m'est arrivé j'ai
pas fait le malheur margot là rien à se
reprocher elle se doute pas du tout de
ce qui va lui être reprochés et elle se
dit bon bah c'est sûrement à un test de
dépistage de drogue qui était un truc
très fréquent dans son établissement où
apparemment des fois ça me dit ok à la
class ess a appelé trois élèves au pif
pour faire des tests de dépistage
incroyable bref le cpe amène margot et
son ami dans une salle de conférence
dans laquelle se trouvent deux policiers
en entrant dans la pièce margot sans
qu'il se passe quelque chose de grave
parce que le policier verrouille à clé
la porte est le deuxième policier bloque
la fenêtre et en vrai c'est des
situations même si t'as rien à te
reprocher tu dis waouh
là il ya des policiers devant moi ils
veulent me poser des questions enfin ça
te met vraiment un maximum de pression
même si t'es rien à te reprocher le cpe
demande alors à margaux si elle a
entendu quelque chose aujourd'hui
margot a aucune idée de quoi parle la
cpe elle lui dit entendu quelque chose à
propos de quoi vous parlez de quoi
lasser peut lui explique qu'il ya des
menaces qui ont été proférées contre
l'école et que le nom de margaux est
apparue dans une conversation
margot comprends rien du tout à ce qui
se passe elle comprend pas pourquoi il
ya eu son nom dans une conversation et
elle comprend pas qui a pu dire que elle
était au courant de ça d'une manière ou
d'une autre la cpe lui explique alors
que marc a proféré des menaces contre
l'école et que lorsqu'ils ont interrogé
d'autres personnes le nom de margaux est
ressorti en gros y'a des gens qui ont
dit à l'école que margot était sûrement
au courant de quelque chose
elle explique qu'elle est pétrifié
pasquet dans une situation où il ya
trois personnes qui agissent comme si
elle avait fait quelque chose de mal de
grave
alors qu'elle a rien fait du tout elle
s'est vraiment pas de quoi ils parlent
bref margot se calme et leur explique
écoutez le seul cours dans lequel je
suis avec lui c'est un cours qui a lieu
de 15h à 16h d'ailleurs aujourd'hui ils
n'étaient pas là et habituellement quand
il est là la seule raison pour laquelle
on parle c'est qu'on a des exercices à
faire ensemble mais c'est tout quoi on
parle pas de nos vies on n'est pas amis
ou quoi que ce soit le cpe lui ne manque
donc si elle est vraiment sûre de ce
qu'elle avance et si elle n'est pas en
train de mentir margot d'ibahn non
vraiment c'est la vérité et au final il
la laisse partir
évidemment retournent en classe tout le
monde lui a posé des tas de questions
sur ce qui venait de se passer et elle a
juste ignorée tout ça le soir en
rentrant chez elle sur facebook
elle voit que l'école a posté un message
parents et élèves de insérer le nom de
l'école deux élèves ont signalé qu'un
autre élève avait menacé notre école
nous avons géré la situation et il n'y a
rien à craindre
bien entendu le message était
probablement plus long et plus précis
mais comme il a été supprimé
c'est tout ce dont il se souvient au
repas du soir margot raconte à ses
parents ce qui s'est passé parce que ben
ça les concerne un peu quand même
et ils ont tout de suite voulu plus
d'information sauf qu'à ce moment-là
margot elle en sait pas plus vraiment
elle a eu aucune réponse ils n'y ont
rien dit elle c'est pas du tout ce qui
se passe et c'est que le lendemain
qu'elle va obtenir les réponses à toutes
ces questions le lendemain margot
apprend que le plan de marx était de
tuer des élèves
en fait lors de la première heure de
cours de la journée marque était là il a
montré à ses camarades de classe une
liste de noms d'élèves en disant qu'il
voulait les tuer et sur cette liste le
troisième non c'était celui de margaux
ses autres élèves ayant rapporté
l'incident alors professeur qu'il a
rapporté à la police mark a été arrêté
lors de la quatrième heure de cours de
la journée et son plan devait se
dérouler pendant la cinquième heure de
cours de la journée qui est l'heure de
cours pendant laquelle margot est assise
à côté de marck
heureusement les élèves en ont parlé
puisque la police en fouillant le casier
de marque est tombé sur une arme à feu
ce qui veut dire que ce n'était pas une
blague ou un truc pour attirer de la
tension autour de lui c'était réel
c'était sérieux bref deux semaines plus
tard margot est toujours pas bien parce
que je vous rappelle que son nom était
sur cette liste et qu'elle a jamais eu
un comportement déplacé avec marc bref
elle n'a jamais rien fait qui puisse
justifier le fait que mark en est après
elle et elle va au supermarché avec son
père en rentrant dans le magasin pour
acheter le repas du soir
margot se décompose puisqu'elle tombe
face à face avec marc margot et son père
sont en panique
non seulement parce que marquer en
totale liberté malgré ce qu'ils
s'apprêtaient à faire et qu'en plus il
sait où margot habite puisqu'il est dans
le supermarché qui est à côté de chez
elle
bref margot et son père sont donc
reparti illico du supermarché et sont
rentrés chez eux et ils ont bien entendu
contacté l'école en leur disant mais
attendez le marque là il est encore dans
les parages en fait qu'est ce qui se
passe est en fait malheureusement pour
eux l'école a agi comme si issue
réagissait par rapport à la situation
l'école leur a dit mais attendait cette
histoire a été réglé tout est sous
contrôle on a fait tout ce qu'il fallait
vous paniquez pour rien faites nous
confiance
en gros selon l'école margot n'a jamais
vraiment été en danger alors que
clairement elle l'a plus quitté margot
explique qu'au moment où elle raconte
cette histoire est la plus d'angoissé
parce que marquer en prison pour avoir
apparemment assassiné sa mère il
l'aurait poussé dans des escaliers et
elle aurait été retrouvée morte dans un
sac mortuaire marbre est donc rassuré
parce qu'il a été condamné pour homicide
volontaire donc il a pris beaucoup
d'années elle ne redoute donc plus qu'un
jour ils se pointent à l'école ou qu'un
jour ils pointent devant chez elle ou au
supermarché dans le but de
lui faire du mal voire de l'assassiner
voilà c'est très gai cette histoire
c'est profondément triste et en france
on a de la chance parce que il ya tout
un truc de régulation sur les armes à
feu et c'est vraiment tant mieux aux us
c'est pas le cas c'est pas en libre
accès non plus mais c'est beaucoup plus
facile de se procurer une arme et du
coup il ya eu beaucoup de tueries dans
des écoles des élèves quand peuvent plus
et qui décide de tuer d'autres élèves
bref c'est hyper triste et c'est un truc
qui a failli arriver à margaux elle est
passé vraiment pas loin ça s'est joué à
une heure près et en plus le gars qui
allait passer à l'acte lui en voulait
personnellement sans qu'elle n'ait
jamais compris pourquoi finale horrible
on arrive donc à la dernière histoire
l'histoire de maeva alors maeva pour
qu'on comprenne bien la suite des
événements elle nous a fait un schéma de
son appart l'investissement de maeva
quoi elle raconte un truc c'est
incroyable et le truc important à
retenir sur ce schéma c'est que les
balcons ne sont pas séparés par des
parois elles sont séparés par un petit
mur que tu peux enjambées et qui en plus
ne couvre pas toute la largeur du balcon
il est donc très simple pour quelqu'un
de se rendre sur le balcon de l'autre
vous sentez les problèmes arrivent et
maeva explique que l'année dernière
après avoir passé un an nickel dans son
nouvel appareil
elle a un nouveau voisin pour le reste
de cette histoire elle va l'appeler sa
maman raconte sa première rencontre avec
ce nouveau voisin et ça s'est passé sur
le parking de l'immeuble
il était en train de décharger les
courses de son énorme camion maeva se
garent à côté du camion elle voit ce
gars avec ce qui a l'air d'être sa
copine et en sortant de la voiture d'un
coup elle constate que les deux ne parle
plus alors fait un signe de la tête pour
leur dire bonjour puis elle rejoint
l'ascenseur pour aller dans son appart
mais pendant qu'elle attend l'ascenseur
le gars se ruent vers elle fait tomber
la moitié des courses qu'il avait dans
ses bras et lui demande de l'attendre
mais elle va se retrouve donc avec son
nouveau voisin est la copine de son
nouveau voisin dans l'ascenseur la
petite amie de ce nouveau voisin baisse
la tête et nine regarde maeva ni ne lui
parle en revanche son nouveau voisin lui
il est extrêmement bavards dans les 45
secondes qu'il faut pour arriver à
l'étagé où se trouvent les appartements
et les le temps de lui demander si elle
aimait l'endroit d'où elles venaient et
où elle travaille avec le recul maeva
trouve que son enthousiasme était un peu
étrange mais elle a pas relevé une nuit
environ trois mois après que sam soit
arrivé là
le petit ami de maeva l'a rejoint chez
elles elles ont regardé des films sur le
canapé il était genre 23h30 site
frenchleaks un fils tu connais et my way
son copain commence à entendre des
bruits de claquements s'entendent des
claques
maeva et son copain tape une bonne barre
et ils se disent ah bah ils passent du
bon temps là bas ça fait plaisir allez
en augmentation de notre série et puis
après un moment en plus
coup il ya eu des cris maeva n'arrive
pas à distinguer ce qu'ils disent mais
elle sans qu' il ya une embrouille son
petit ami se rend alors sur la terrasse
se penche sur le balcon de sam est dit
est ce que tout va bien là dans une ou
deux minutes plus tard la copine de sam
ouvre la porte coulissante du balcon et
dit oui tout va bien désolé pour le
bruit vous en faites pas du coup on
m'avait son copain ne se sont pas
inquiétés plus que ça et ils sont allés
se coucher
bref cette nuit-là maeva se réveille
environ 3 heures du matin à cause du rpt
le mans de plus en plus fort mais comme
elle était dans les vapes elle n'a pas
vraiment distinguer si c'était un
mauvais rêve liés à ce qu'elle avait
entendues vers 23h30
aussi il se passait vraiment de nouveau
un truc pas cool à côté et du coup elle
s'est rendormi
bref avance rapide d'environ deux
semaines pendant lesquelles et c'est
rien repassé de similaire c'est une
belle journée chaude maeva elle est en
robe sur son balcon elle kiffe la vie
quand d'un coup elle sent une tape sur
son épaule et s'agit bien entendu de sam
qui est sur le balcon de maeva et que
lui demandent s'ils peuvent parler une
minute il vient donc de pénétrer dans
l'appart de maeva dans un calme
grandiloquent et en plus il est entre
maeva et la porte coulissante qui lui
permet d'accéder à son appart donc mais
elle va lé zot sa m'expliquer maeva que
c'est son anniversaire et que comme elle
ressemble à une fille qui a l'air de
savoir s'amuser ils aimeraient qu'elle
lui donne un bon plan pour acheter de la
weed
il faut savoir que la wii de là-haut
maeva habitent c'est légal vu le
comportement que ça m'a eue de venir sur
son balcon en ignorant la frontière etc
elle lui dit bah écoute mais franchement
vu que c'est légal va sur google tu
auras vraiment toutes les réponses dont
tu as besoin et alors que maeva commence
à se lever pour rentrer chez elle samedi
remet la main sur l'épaule et lui
explique qu'il a éraflé sa voiture la
nuit dernière parce qu'il conduisait un
peu bourré wahaha et lui dit ça avec un
sourire sur le visage comme s'il était
content que ce soit arrivé
maeva elle est surprise et choquée de
comment il lui dit ça dans un calme
incroyable mais elle est sur la
défensive parce qu'il a rien à [ __ ]
sur son balcon et du coup elle lui dit
ok ok pas grave on verra ça plus tard je
veux rentrer chez moi
bref le lendemain c'est le jour j de
l'événement terrible on est samedi il
est 23h maeva elle est chez elle elle en
train de regarder un bon gros film
d'action qui est donc relativement
bruyant et du coup il faut un peu de
temps avant de comprendre qu' il ya des
gens qui tapent à sa porte
elle baisse le son de son film et elle
entend les mots suivants police ouvrez
la porte
d'accord pourtant il ya pas de margaux
là dans l'histoire maeva alors une
énorme boule au ventre je pense comme
tout le monde qui entend ces mots de
toute manière elles veulent effet quand
même dans l'oeil de la porte si c'est
bien des policiers qui sont sur le
palier c'est bien des policiers ils sont
six et ils ont tous un fusil d'assaut
c'est bon ça fait peur de voir des gars
et des armes qui toquent chetouane une
cd policiers ça fait super peur
heureusement le capitaine des policiers
qui est sur le palier sans que maeva lé
pas sereine et il la rassure et lui dit
madame vous avez aucun souci à vous
faire on n'est pas là pour vous du tout
est ce que s'il vous plaît vous pouvez
nous laisser entrer chez vous maeva et
les en pls total elle ouvre la porte les
policiers rentrent chez elles et le
capitaine des policiers lui demandent du
coup qu'elles ont été cette dernière
interaction avec sam
maeva leur explique qu'elle le connaît à
peine qu'elle l'a vu quelques fois qu'il
a emménagé que ya quelques mois et puis
elle leur demande pourquoi ils ont
besoin d'être dans son appart et le
capitaine de la police lui répond tout
simplement que sam est très dangereux et
que la nuit précédente
il a battu sa copine tellement fort
qu'elle s'est retrouvée en soins
intensifs
il lui explique alors qu'ils savent que
sam a un pistolet et qu'il est barricadé
chez lui donc dans l'appartement à côté
du sien les policiers disent donc à
maeva d'aller dans sa chambre de
verrouiller la porte et d'éteindre les
lumières pendant que vaut procéder à une
intervention chez sam via le balcon même
les 30 minutes qui chute pour maeva
elles sont horribles exactement comme
pour elliott dans la panique elle n'a
pas pris son téléphone qui se trouve sur
la table de sa cuisine et du coup elle
est dans une chambre dans le noir à
entendre des policiers crier sur un mec
sans qu'elle ne puisse faire quoi que ce
soit à part attendre après 30 minutes
l'intervention des policiers est
terminée et heureusement il ya eu aucun
coup de feu de tirer le capitaine
retourne donc voir maeva dans sa chambre
et lui explique que l'intervention est
terminée et que sam a été arrêté mais
valve est vrai que l'histoire elle se
termine là sauf que ça se termine pas là
cinq jours plus tard maeva rentre du
travail et en rentrant dans l'ascenseur
elle voit un homme qui se met à courir
pour attraper l'ascenseur avec elle et
cet homme c'est sam sam lui demande
alors pourquoi elle a laissé rentrer les
policiers chez elle ce soir là et elle
lui explique la vérité qu'elle était
pétrifié et du coup elle voulait surtout
pas passer pour une complice de quoi que
ce soit ou avoir d'autres problèmes avec
la police
évidemment il en veut à maeva d'avoir
fait ça et il va lui proposer un truc
scandaleux il va lui proposer trois
mille dollars pour qu'elle témoigne en
sa faveur puisque selon lui elle le
connaît et elle sait comment il traite
vraiment les femmes et à quel point
c'est un homme bon maeva évidemment elle
n'a pas envie de témoigner pour un mec
qui a failli tuer sa copine elle sait
plus trop comment elle s'en est sorti
mais elle s'en est sortie elle a dit des
trucs qui font que au final il lui a
foutu la paix quelques jours plus tard
on est mercredi soir on est la veille du
procès de sam
maeva rentrent chez elles après le
travail et elle constate que son chat un
comportement un peu bizarre il est
stressé et c'est là qu'elle remarque à
travers les rideaux qu'il ya un post it
collé à sa vitre et ce post it c'est sam
qui avait mis là est dessus il avait
marqué son numéro de téléphone
la phrase suivante je compte sur vous
quel genre de père vers tétouan quel
genre de père verte est bien évidemment
maeva ne s'est pas rendu au procès elle
a pris une photo du post-it elle a
verrouillé toutes ses portes à clé avant
de se rendre chez sa mère et 10 passes
et les cinq jours suivants elle explique
qu'elle n'a plus jamais revu sam et
qu'il a donc très probablement perdu son
procès et quelques semaines plus tard
elle a même vu une femme dans
l'appartement de sam qui nettoyaient et
c'était en fait probablement la
propriétaire qui remettait à 9
la parte avant de le relouer à d'autres
personnes voilà l'histoire de maeva et
elle est assez touchante parce que je
sais que pendant le confinement il est
pas mal d'histoires comme ça en fait du
coup comme tout le monde et chez soi il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont entendu des
trucs pas naître dans l'appart d'un côté
et c'est franchement c'est difficile de
savoir ce que tu fais dans une situation
comme ça où tu entend des bruits dans la
part d'un côté en fait ça peut te
semblait irréel mais non ça arrive et ça
arrive beaucoup plus qu'on ne le pense
c'est un petit moral un peu bas dante
mais c'est pour ça qu'elle m'a touché
cette histoire et j'ai trouvé horrible
et surtout plus tard dans les trois cas
ça a failli être bien pire que ce à quoi
les événements c'est terrible en tout
cas j'espère qu'il fera l'histoire vous
ont plu moi j'ai trois parfaitement
horrible je vous souhaite à tous de très
bonne chose désolée si votre voisin
s'appelle sam désolé si votre camarade
de classe s'appelle mark ne vous en
faites pas ça y est je vous dis à
bientôt un bisou de maman le bisou maman
qui fait mal à l'oreille
[Musique]